[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
sunglow here in big no utah my name is
bessie stewart and today we're going to
make our famous pickle pie
[Music]
pickle pie is a dessert it's not the
sweetest pie we have but it is the
most original took a lot of imagination
i think to invent a dessert pie with a
pickle in it the original owner found
the recipe in a magazine she didn't like
the recipe at all so she changed it
around and now the pickle pie is the
very best as far as i know we are the
only place that makes the pickle pie
[Music]
in pickle pie you will find sugar butter
milk eggs lemon extract corn starch
cinnamon nutmeg and of course the
pickles
so we've got this all mixed in really
nice and smooth so now we're going to
pour it into our unbaked pie shell
to put in the oven
scrape the edges so you get all the
flavor and this one right here
is one that we baked this morning
wow
pickle pie
this is delicious
a little tiny bit of cream on it just
gives it that little bit of sweet and
sour that you need to set off the taste
buds
so
[Music]
the customers like the pickle pie but i
think the biggest selling point is
curiosity
this looks like a delicious pie it
tastes very similar to a pumpkin pie
it's got a
well nickel to it but it's not like
overpowering or anything good flavor
kind of sweet a little sweet it's like
super sweet it's
not
really sweet
[Music]
i think it's going to sell
bricknall is a very small little town we
are about three hours from salt lake
city and you don't have to live in a
great big city to have good food you
have to have pride
and an imagination
it's more than just a pie
it's your work of art it's something
that you have done
and it looks pretty and it tastes good
and you can be proud of it
in the united kingdom pie is a king
not just for the cherries and the apples
that you yanks are used to you have your
chicken your steak and kidney your pork
pie
and in one tiny fishing town you have
this a pie with
what wait is it is that fish head
oh you've gotta be kidding me
trust me you're going to love it
in this tiny fishing village there's a
pub and in that pub they make stargazey
pie
it's a tradition that legend has it has
been happening here for hundreds of
years which begs the question why the
starry gazey pie is a pie which
celebrates tombow cox going out and
catching seven different kinds of fish
on the 23rd of december
you see according to the legend it had
been a stormy winter this meant no boat
managed to go out of the fish so people
were starving but a local fisherman tom
bocox he wasn't going to let his people
die i'm going he went out through the
gate yes that gate and braved the storm
and
and caught the different kinds of fish
and brought it back he made the pie
and that brings us to today tracy take
it away
you get six different white fish bake
that in the oven with some herbs and
some lemon zest put a layer of grated
eggs a nice mashed potato with loads of
cream in and then you put a pastry lid
put pilchards cut them and then you put
so that the heads are coming out the pie
and the tails are coming out the pie you
assemble all the stars around the pie
on the 23rd of december we give it away
free to thousands of people that come to
the village to celebrate tombo cox night
so to tom bocox what a legend cheers tom
so should we taste it
that is good
delicious that really is quite delicious
it's good
really good
fish is lovely it's most interesting
it's it's much milder than i thought
[Music]
fishbone
[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel
all consumed with tasting something
again that you haven't had in years and
years that's really what i'm doing here
is bringing back those incredible
desserts those incredible experiences
that have gone extinct
i put myself through this process of
resurrecting desserts because i truly
feel that a good dessert can change the
course of your day
i'm valerie gordon owner of valerie
confections and i'm also a dessert
anthropologist
the way this
project of resurrecting historic
desserts began
was in 2009 the food editor from the los
angeles times magazine asked me to
create a blums coffee crunch cake for an
article that she was doing
and it was this amazing full circle
moment because i grew up with that cake
i know that cake and i missed that cake
terribly
blums was an incredible bakery and cafe
in california there were eight locations
the last one closed in the 80s when the
article came out we literally received
125 phone calls from people going oh my
god i want this cake
the desserts that i resurrected to date
are of course the coffee crunch cake the
blums
i've brought back the banana shortcake
from chasen's
the brown derby grapefruit cake is
another cake that i've resurrected
and now is soon to be the coffiesta
sundae as well
[Music]
the
anthropology of the dessert resurrection
is really one of the most
interesting parts of all of this
i start the research process at the
central library
there is a room and this is a very well
guarded room called the menu vault
there are menus that date back for 150
years
i find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online because
you're really getting to the heart and
soul of the place you're almost
transported
into that place at that time by holding
something that these people held you
really are
[Music]
then i email a bunch of people or i call
a bunch of people who
were natives to los angeles or whatever
city the bakery was in
to find out hey do you remember this do
you remember that we always used to call
this the adult sunday because this is
the one my mom would eat can they
describe the texture of a whipped cream
can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not i'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then flavored
accordingly right it was little kid
whipped cream one cherry yes
this is amazing like you you have been
indispensable
i'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about reliving those sense
memories
it's sort of like when you hear a song
that was your favorite song from 1982
you're really thrown back
into that moment it's become this very
emotional very fulfilling part of my job
to bring these cakes back for people
[Music]
these little custard tarts these eggy
sugary treats are everywhere in portugal
here here and here some say the
pistachio belang is the original paste
dinata or custard tart
in this little factory through this
kitchen there's a recipe that has been
kept top secret for almost 200
not this one guys i can't get in here
i'm sorry
[Music]
okay i'm miguel clerini and i'm part of
the management of prestige blind
this special recipe you will only find
here at this shop we sell an average of
about 20 000 tarts a day in the summer
maybe around 40 000 cakes
a lot of cakes
the stage the belang as they call them
here are simple tarts really egg yolk
milk some flour sugar but it's how they
make them in complete secrecy that makes
these tarts a national treasure
we have six people knowing the recipe
in the family
my father my cousin and myself miguel
the three chefs which is vitor dominguez
eliseo jamiro and carlos martinez
the recipe is so secret all the bakers
signed non-disclosure agreements to keep
the timeless tarts a true mystery
staged blaine
is one of the earliest recipes at least
here in lisbon we know that the recipe
was invented in the monastery of
in the early 19th century
this one
once they have the recipe the chefs now
sworn to secrecy are giving keys to this
door
they work inside the factory in a
separate room that we call the ofcene
in portuguese it's like the secret shop
or secret room they have to work in a
separate room because the process can
only be seen by them so today we haven't
found anyone that
explained the recipe as it is if it
happened well we probably would have to
lock him up in the basement and
throw away the key
no just kidding
okay secret keeper what's the best way
to eat one of these custard tarts
usually i like it uh simple but that's
just me most people like with a little
bit of cinnamon on top
no
this is the hard part of the job
[Music]
yeah this is super hard
i don't know how you do it